What's up, guys?
Ready to join Dom and I on our adventure in Korea?
Welcome to the heart and soul of Korea.
The only thing I was looking forward to was this.
Let me show you how Korea shows their hospitality.
You get a nail file, cotton pads, toothbrush and toothpaste with mouthwash...
...long hair must-have, they hooked it.
Whenever I'm visiting a new country, I like to try their traditional food.
They gave us lotus tea to start.
It was so good.
We decided to hit up one of the most famous districts in Korea.
Can you guess?
Yup, Gangnam.
Like Beverly Hills or Fifth Avenue, this is the place to shop and play.
Korea is innovating the beauty space.
Their products and formula are unique and forward-thinking.
We spent the entire afternoon sampling everything.